you're so good with voices you do such
distinct voices a lot of Canadians out
there that do hear bit do little accents
little things but yours are very
distinct did you start doing voices when
you were a kid I did I've always done it
I think when you're bad at sports you
develop other strengths no I wouldn't
know yeah me neither I assume I'm I'm a
professional football player yes I can
tell yeah you know but yeah I did a lot
of voices and I'm really proud of it but
recently I was told that I do the worst
Arnold Schwarzenegger impression of all
time the worst one of all time that's
hard because there are a lot of bad
Swartz [ __ ] impressions out there you
say you have the worst I believe I I am
holding the worst what makes it so bad
let me tell you number one I picked a
line that is not famous oh it's not like
I'll be back or something one of the
classes I've never heard of that one I
didn't even pick the it's not a tumor
which is a great line as well by the
governor but I chose it from a movie
that's also like not I mean all the
Arnold movies are classic American films
but I chose a line from twins which I
always thought was about I thought it
was Arnold gets pregnant with a baby and
has the baby out of its butt and the
baby is Danny DeVito and that's not what
it's about
I think you're thinking of jr. it was a
junior why am i engaging in I don't know
they can't have a baby out of your butt
Conan yeah so anyway so you picked
wanted to do that I know it comes up you
can try it but anyway so you picked a
line from the movie Junior and good know
from twins see it's already bad cuz
they're like what is that okay and
here's what it is it's Arnold just like
really strong cuz he's Arnold and he's
has a briefcase and a man runs by and he
tries to steal the briefcase but Arnold
is like so strong that the man's like
who you know and he falls on the floor
and then Arnold
goes I did nothing the Baron throws at
the end of it
what
[Applause]
line I didn't even hear did you hear the
line I did nothing bad if he's arriving
no I did not think the pavement was the
enemy no I did nothing I did nothing the
pavement was his enemy
that's the worst line I've ever heard
so you pick and pick the worst line yeah
I did nothing the pavement was his enemy
first line ever said by Arnold that
includes his work from jingle all the
way and you then do a horrible you said
you saw that Grover from Sesame Street